foreign
[Music]
exclusive backstage with Janet Jackson
just hours before she performed in front
of a sold out Madison Square Garden
crowd
what does this one mean to you this
one's special I mean it's my 50th
anniversary in the industry I started
young what's your name Janet it means a
great deal to me and to still
have God allow me to do what it is that
I do I'm so appreciative and this time
around the 56 year old is hitting the
road as a mom to her now six-year-old
son Issa
you now have a six-year-old how is that
because that six-year-old is a
personality a full person he's great I
wish I had two more babies you're like I
could have more and more and more yeah I
wish I had two more babies I love it I'm
I'm just thankful God gave me
four three two one
Janet you know I think we all reach a
point in life where we're happy and like
this has been a great tour for you so
far it's the most fun
nation that I've had
[Applause]
hard to believe it's been 23 years since
that iconic tour and E.T was there
hopefully uh through my music and the
dance I will inspire
the audience
it's very very intricate you know your
head's going this way your hands are
open this way this one's done here and
your legs are doing something else oh
Janet still has the moves her together
Again Tour consists of 40 songs and four
acts and four wardrobe changes including
this look by Christian siriano
so Christian what is it like
designing for Janet Jackson because
she's had some of the most iconic looks
so much pressure and so the only
pressure you can possibly have in this
business you can't say no like Janet
calls and you're saying yeah of course
you can see no can we talk about this
how did you come up with this yeah this
is our little sketch I mean I think it
originally you know how Jenna explained
it to me was this our section I mean it
shows in sections you know it was more
the club a little fun
um having a moment there so we went for
color and
um texture and playfulness and I think
we had a lot of fun
down the road maybe some new music oh
yeah I shouldn't say it like that yeah I
get in there I'm just really taking my
time within so yeah I've been in and out
of the studio
well we'll see in the meantime Janet is
working on an upcoming documentary Janet
Jackson family first which could lead to
her reuniting the family band after 40
years
what would it mean for all y'all to get
back together oh it would be special
especially for me because that hasn't
happened since I was a kid
foreign